psychologen haben mit mir gesprochen um
mich auf das testergebnis vorzubereiten
ich habe gedacht dass ich sterben werde
wir glaubten das ebola den tod bedeutet
aber die ärzte sagten mir dass ich mich
erholen würde
ich habe keine angst weil ich weiß wie
man mit infizierten umgehen muss und
welche sicherheitsvorkehrungen wir
helfen
seit über einem jahr bietet ebola wieder
in der demokratischen republik kongo
seitdem starben fast 2000 menschen an
dem virus
die krankheit breitet sich schnell aus
eine berührung reicht um sich zu
infizieren die menschen wurden in die
irre geführt wurde zu lange erzählt das
ebola keine reale krankheit ist sondern
nur eine erfindung mit der geld gemacht
wird